et réclament le droit à mourir dans la
dignité quand le corps et l'esprit sont
absents et que les malades peuvent
encore le réclamer pour abréger leurs
souffrances
le droit à l'euthanasie n'existe pas en
france contrairement aux pays bas au
luxembourg ou encore en belgique c'est
dans ce dernier pays à liège qu'un
habitant de château renault a accompagné
sa femme en décembre 2018 pour son
dernier voyage un témoignage recueilli
par hélène chapelet je suis atteinte de
deux maladies incurables polyarthrite
rhumatoïde et maladie de parkinson un
niveau particulièrement handicapant mon
état physique étant irréversible
elles n'ayant plus la capacité
d'effectuer aucun des gestes
élémentaires de la vie quotidienne je
demande que l'on m'aide à mourir
dignement cette lettre c'est andré qui
l'a rédigé le 2 décembre 2010 8 à 77 ans
quinze jours avant son euthanasie à
l'hôpital de liège en belgique
les pousses de gilbert ne voulait pas
perdre sa dignité elle a donc demandé à
son mari et à ses trois enfants de
l'aider à mourir
elles ne pouvaient plus effectuer les
les gestes de la vie quotidienne se
lavait se vêtir se nourrir
c'est ce qui l'a motivé de ne souhaitait
pas évidemment terminée et grabataire
c'est elle qui était coquette cn était
impensable pour elle la face à sa
détermination le moi et mes enfants
décidons de l'accompagner tout le monde
a tout de suite adhéré à sa fin à sa
demande nous l'avons accompagné tous
jusqu'à la fin un médecin vous reçoit et
examine votre canne dans le cadre
justement de dans le projet d'euthanasie
et ensuite un deuxième avis médical est
nécessaire avant que le premier médecin
qui vous a pris en charge décide de de
pratiquer l'euthanasie ensuite
l'euthanasie se pratique par un
par injection létale c'est très doux et
très très très rapide procédures ça a
été c'était un moment fort c'est pas
facile à vivre parce que vous perdez
vous perdez l'être cher en direct
suivant mais mais je pense qu'ils
étaient il fallait le faire
nous avons bien fait et donc moi j'ai
décidé de militer au sein de la dmd
l'association pour le droit à mourir
dans la dignité
afin de d'aider d'autres personnes que
mon témoignage serve à quelque chose